Transcriber: Aylin Dincer
Gözden geçirme: Ozay Ozaydin
Merhabalar ben Reha Özcan.
Rahmetli babam kitap okuma hevesini ilk
yakaladığım zamanlarda heyecanıma
sevinmiş ama çaresiz bir sevinçle
bana şunları söylemişti.
Biz insanoğlu denize
düşen bir süngeriz sadece.
Çekebildiğimiz kadar su çekeriz.
Denizi bitirme şansımız yoktur ama su
yaşama sevincimiz olur her zaman.
İki şey çok önemli derdi.
İyi bir eş ve iyi bir iş.
Eğer bunları bulursan ve korursan zamanın
nasıl geçtiğini anlamazsın.
Buna da mutluluk derler.
Fakat bunların ikisi de seni sürekli
yenilenme ve gelişmeye ve öğrenmeye iten
özgürlük alanlarıdır derdi.
Tutabilirsen taze,
mutluluğun resmini çizdin demektir Abidin.
Teşekkür ederim.
Okumayı sevdiğim kadar okuduklarımı
birilerine anlatmayı da severdim.
İnsanları bunaltırdım, sıkılırlardı.
Öyle olduğu zaman sıkılmayan
insanları da bulurdum.
Onlara anlatırdım.
16 yaşımdaydım.
12 Eylül’ün o kasvetli karanlığında
kendinize ideal olarak seçtiğiniz
işe ulaşmak o kadar kolay değildi.
Kendinizi ifade edecek
işi bulmak çok zordu.
Yegane işim olan oyunculuğa ulaşmak için,
tanışmak için başka
mesleklerle de tanıştım.
Pazarcılık yaptım, pazarlamacılık, işte
garsonluk, hatta kamyon muavinliği yaptım.
Son seferimde bizim Kaptan Celal Gün’ü
sorularımla ve muhabbetimle öyle
bunaltmıştım ki onun gönlünü alabilmek
için yahu usta dedim boşver
dedim hiç değilse ben burada, yanındayım
ne güzel işte gidiyoruz, uğurlu
geldim.
Ne lastik patladı ne de cam patladı dedim.
Yüz kilometre içinde önce
lastik
sonra da ön cam patlayınca beni kovdu.
Ve o zamanlar çok para kazanılan
bir iş değildi oyunculuk.
Zira oyunculuk sadece tiyatro demekti.
Olsun, ne olacak, yaşasın çok param
olmayacaktı ama en azından babamın bana
öğrettiği ilk şeye kavuşacaktım.
Yani mutlu olacağım bir iş .
Bizim işimiz
çok basit bir şeye dayanıyor.
Biriktirip boşaltma döngüsüne.
Aslında bütün işler üç aşağı böyledir.
Yeni coğrafyalar, yeni iklimler.
Yeni yüzler aramak zordur.
Fakat çok kıymetlidir.
Demek istediğim.
İşini seven ve oyunu en az sizin kadar
ciddiye alan oyun arkadaşları
bulmaya gayret edin.
Ve bu arayışta önyargılarınızdan lütfen
sıyrılın. Hayatı boyunca bambaşka bir
alanda uzmanlık yapmak zorunda,
eğitim almak zorunda kalan biri,
kendi yaşam tecrübeleriyle beraber sizin
alanınıza girdiğinde inanılmaz bir
katalizöre dönüşebilir.
Oyun ciddi bir iştir.
Şeyi düşünsenize.
Yani böyle kendi kendine
bloklarla oynayan
bir çocuğu düşünün.
Ondan nasıl haz aldığını.
Bazıları haz almaz, onlarla
ilgilenmiyoruz.
Nasıl kaybolur?
Kendini tamamen oraya kaptırıp
Tak tak, tak, tak, tak tak yapar.
İçinizde çocuk sahibi olan var mı ?
Malumunuz olduğu üzere bu zaman zaman
çok iyiye işaret değildir.
Ama bir gün, gerçekten bir gün
Her birimiz, hepiniz, istisnasız
oyunun ciddiye alınmayacak,
neredeyse gereksiz bir şey
olduğuna inandırılırız.
Kurallar ve kurallar girer hayatımıza.
Okul, dersler, statü kaygısı,
askerlik, bir meslek sahibi olmak,
çoluk çocuk.
Ve yavaş yavaş o oyuncu karakterimizle
vedalaşırız.
Meslek olarak oyunu seçenlerimiz
için bile bu böyle.
Profesyonel bilgisayar oyuncularından
tutun, sporculardan tutun, bizim gibi
sahneye çıkıp orada nefes alıp
veren insanlara kadar herkes.
Oyunun
mesleğiniz haline gelmesi
bir ayrıcalıktır.
Ben konservatuvardan mezun olduğumun
ertesi günü, devlet tiyatrosuna atanan
şanslı nesildenim. İçinizden
bazıları oh ne güzel
ye böreği, yat aşağı diyor olabilirsiniz.
Ama,
sanıyorum çoğunuzdan yaşça büyüğümdür,
Ama bugün bazen
dönüyorum bakıyorum da keşke diyorum,
keşke öğrendiklerimin birçoğunu,
öğretilenlerin birçoğunu
bir unutabilseydim.
Keşke.
Ve her şeyi, bütün o ekolleri,
bütün dinamikleri,
bütün disiplinleri kendi çabamla,
deneye yanıla, deneye yanıla, kendi
nefesimi, kendi sesimi, kendi duruşumu
keşke çok daha önce yapabilseydim.
Ancak
bu şekilde yaptığımız zaman, bu süreci
kendiniz yönettiğiniz zaman
gerçekte nasıl bir oyuncu olduğunuzu
anlayabiliyorsunuz çünkü.
Tabii iş olarak
tiyatroyu kendine meslek olarak
seçmiş biri olarak bu lüksü
nankörlük edip küçümsemeyeceğim.
35 sene neredeyse Devlet Tiyatroları’nda
bir asker disipliniyle
çalıştım.
Ve oradaki oyun denemeleri, deneyleri
benim yaşamıma çok büyük şeyler kattı.
Aşırı miktarda oyun oynadım ama.
Herhalde devlet tiyatrosunun
en çok oynayan oyuncularından biriyim.
60'ın üzerinde oyun oynadım.
Eğer işini seven bir oyuncuysan
ve her şeye rağmen
işini yapmaya devam edebiliyorsan
yöneticiler tarafından
yeteneklerimiz falan hiç önemli değil.
Siz sürdürülebilir bir enerji
kaynağı olarak görülürsünüz.
Çok sevdiğim ama söylerken
içimi acıtan bir şey var.
Sen işi bırakmadın, iş seni terk etti.
Oyun işiniz olduğunda bir mühendis ya da
bilim insanı gibi her gün aynı disiplinle
öğrenmeye devam etmek zorundasınız.
Fark ettiniz mi bilmiyorum
ama bilim insanı dedim.
Bunu da yeni öğrendim.
Bilim adamı demedim.
Öğreniyoruz işte.
Ama hoşuma gitti.
Güzelmiş.
Şeyler vardır ya, video oyunlarında
ilerledikçe yeni
karakterler, ek görevler falan girer,
haritalar falan.
İşte tiyatroda da bu böyledir.
Farklı bir şey değildir.
Sizi sürprizleriyle şaşırtmaya
hazırdır tiyatro.
Ama birinci levelda takılıp da ben
oynamıyorum derseniz,
işte o zaman siz oyunu değil,
oyun sizi terk eder ve sonsuza kadar
bir daha asla gelmez.
Geçenlerde bu konuşmaya hazırlanırken
Oya ile yeni bir şey keşfettim.
O söyledi, ben bilmiyordum.
Tabi benim için yeni de sizin
için yeni olmayabilir.
Her öğrencinin en sevdiği ders var ya.
İstatistik.
İşte onu alanlar varsa
aranızda onlar anlar.
Sıfır toplamlı oyun.
Bakın ben bunu bilmiyordum.
Bazı oyunlarda biri kazanmak diğeri
ise kaybetmek zorundaymış.
Yalnızca 2 rol var.
1 ve -1.
İkisinin toplamı sıfır.
Ben bunu anlayamıyorum
çünkü beni ürkütüyor böyle bir düşünce.
Biz tiyatroda hep çoğaltmaya
odaklandığımız için ilk duyduğumda
hiçbir anlam veremedim.
Neden iki taraf da kazanamıyor
ya da berabere bitmiyor?
Ama sonra fark ettim çoğu zaman
biz hayata hep böyle yaklaşmıyor muyuz?
Bildiğimiz, oynadığımız, keyif aldığımız
ne varsa, hatta ilişkilerimizde bile.
Skora, ödüle, hı?
Kupaya, sıfata.
İlle de ama ille de bir
sonuca bağlanmıyor mu?
Ya berabere işte, yenişemedik. Niye
illa penaltılara gidiyor anlamıyorum ki.
Oyunun kendisinden keyif almayı
biz ne zaman ve nerede kaybettik?
Niye kaybettik?
Bakın 2002 yılında Antalya'da yaşıyordum.
Tatilya’ya götürdü beni abim.
Tatilya’yı biliyor... O kadar
yapmayın, jenerasyon farkı yoktur.
Tatilya diye bir yer vardı.
Orada 5 boyutlu bir film seyrettim.
Hani şimdi bir sürü AVM’de var.
Hani dönüp bakmadığımız
o teknoloji var ya.
O zamanlar çok yeniydi.
Bugün gibi aklımda.
Bakın.
Önce bir odaya giriyorsunuz, size ne
olacağını anlatıyorlar, neler yapmanız
gerektiğini anlatıyorlar.
Sonra cart diye başka bir kapı açılıyor.
Oradan içeri giriyorsunuz.
Böyle koltuklar var, üçerli
altılı koltuklar var.
Geçiyorsunuz oturu... oturmuyorsunuz,
biniyorsunuz resmen.
Sonra emniyet kemerini takıyorsunuz.
Emniyet kemerini açarsanız bir
anda oyun sona eriyor.
İnanılmaz bir şey.
Hareket ediyor koltuklar.
Su geliyor, koku geliyor.
Rüzgar geliyor.
Tüm duyularınızla filmin içindesin.
Bu benim hayatımın en büyük seyriydi.
Bize konservatuarda tiyatro teorisi
derslerinde öğretilen bir şey vardı.
Çok gizemli bir şey.
Katarsis.
Katarsis. Çok güzel değil mi?
Meğerse bu kadarmış işte.
Bize abarttılar.
Yani oyunun sizi içine alması, sarıp
sarmalaması. Şimdi ve burada, o anda
olmak hep beraber.
Ancak
böyle sahnede, perdede her ne oluyorsa
tüm hücrelerinde hissedebilirsin bunu.
Başka türlü değil.
Eğer oyunsa derdiniz
bundan daha değerli bir şey yok.
Şimdi film neydi hatırlamıyorum bile.
Bir aksiyon filmiydi herhalde.
Bir şelaleden aşağı uçuyorsun, uçurumdan
aşağı böyle atlıyorsun,
balonla yukarılara çıkıyorsun falan.
Çok da önemli bir film
değildi ama çok etkiledi.
Ya, bizim sanatçı arkadaşların
burun kıvırıp hiç beğenmeyecekleri türden
bir aksiyon filmi.
Ama mesele o değildi.
Mesele şuydu.
Oyun dediğimiz şey zaten kenar süsleri
olmadan da gerçek bir heyecana
dönüşebilir değil mi?
Çok basit bir şeyden müthiş bir oyun
alanı yaratabiliriz kendimize.
Ondan sonra da mucizevi
bir an beklersiniz.
Bir ses, bir nefes, bir damla gözyaşı,
bir susuş belki.
İşte bugün bile
adını hatırlamadığım o filmde
ben öyle bir heyecan yaşamıştım.
Edebiyatla şimdi burada tamamen ayrıldık.
Hepsi gitti.
Ben o gün
kendimi o saçma sapan maceranın
içinde bulunca
dedim ki bir yaşayan, bir de ölü
tiyatro var.
Eğer bilim ve teknolojinin ürettiklerini
sahne üzerine çıkartamıyorsak,
bu medeni insanlara biz ne verebiliriz?
Bunun üzerine birçok eğitime katıldım,
workshoplara katıldım, dans atölyelerine
katıldım. Kuklalar, seminerler,
festivaller ama işe yaradı.
Bu çok büyük bir keşif benim için.
Ve nihayet
o 5 boyutlu filmden yararlanarak
teknolojinin tüm nimetlerini
beslediğimiz o oyun sahnelendi.
Topor Parti
Sanat deyince aklınıza gelebilecek
bütün ekoller vardı içinde.
Ölü tiyatroyu orada haşat etmiştik.
Antalya’da devlet tiyatrosunda oynarken
bence muhteşem bir oyun çıkartmıştık.
Ama oyunu prömiyer yaptık.
Bir hafta boyunca 30 kişi vardı
400 kişilik salonda.
Onların yarısı da oyunun yarısında
salonu terk ediyordu.
Sonra oyun Ankara Festivali’ne, Adana
Festivali’ne, İstanbul Festivali’ne,
Romanya'ya gitti.
Bükreş'te oynadık.
Sonra Fransa'ya gittik.
Altı şehirde oynadık, bir sürü yerde
oynadık, bir sürü ödüller aldık.
Çok mutluyduk.
Antalya’ya geri döndük.
Yine 30 kişi.
Kader böyleymiş.
Ama her şeye rağmen bu oynama biçimi
bana yepyeni, kocaman
bir dünya açmıştı.
Ben de
umuda tutunarak ve herkesin
ya deli misin oğlum,
manyak mısın, bu devirde özel tiyatro mu
olur demesine rağmen kendime bir özel
tiyatro açtım.
Düşe kalka, bazen kavga ederek ama
genellikle hep iyiliğe doğru gidebilmek
için bir sürü insan biriktirmişim
çevremde.
Hani babam demişti ya hayatta mutlu
olmak istiyorsan iki şeyden emin ol.
İyi bir iş ve iyi bir eş.
Eşten yana çok şanslıyım. Sanırım.
Fakat babamın
sadece hayat arkadaşından bahsetmediğini
zamanla anladım.
Mutluluğun resmini çizebilmek, şarkısını
söyleyebilmek, şiirini okumak
kolay bir iş değil.
Bunun için çok iyi oyun arkadaşları
biriktirmeniz gerekiyor.
Tek başınıza yaptığınız sadece o
oyuna giden bir antrenmandır.
Hepi topu.
Bu arada sadece yalnızca rekabetten
bahsetmiyorum.
Evet.
Teoride rekabet iyi bir şeydir. Benim için
de öyle ama pratik farklı.
Yani beni 3 bant bilardo oynarken ya da
bir konsol oyununda karşımda olmadan
burada seyrettiğiniz için şanslı
hissediyorum kendimi.
Ama ben bunlara mesai harcamasaydım
muhtemelen sahnede, hatta insan
ilişkilerinde iyi bir oyun
arkadaşı olamazdım.
Biz bugün burada
oyun arkadaşlarımızla yaptığımız
şeye kısaca iyiliğe kaçmak diyoruz.
Ve ya böyle deyince de saçma
sapan bir tarikat gibi görünmesin.
Iyiliğe kaçalım.
Yıllar önce, hani o şehrin yarısının gelip
de yarısında çıktığı oyun
topor partide oyunun yönetmeni
Mehmet Ulusoy’un
bize miras bıraktığı ve
oyun boyunca her oyundan önce yaptığımız
ve bugün de benim tiyatromda oyuna
çıkmadan önce bütün
arkadaşlarla toplanıp
söylediğimiz laf
iyiliğe kaçmak.
Buradan Mehmet Ulusoy'un
ruhu şad olsun diyorum.
Ben çok şanslı bir oyuncuyum.
Çok değerli yönetmenler, çok değerli
oyuncularla tanıştım.
Çok yol kat ettim ama yorulmadım.
Mesleğimin tüm disiplinleri ile tanıştım.
Bir sürü ödül aldığım doğrudur.
Fakat en büyük ödül, oyunu seyrettikten
sonra babamın gelip omuzuma dokunup
aferin oğlum demesiydi.
Babamı 2016′da kaybettim.
Kazanmak ve kaybetmek kavramlarından
sıyrılıp yenisi için yola
düşmeye hep hazırım.
Sahneye çıkıp çıkmayacağını bilmediğim bir
metinle boğuşmak, hiç dilini, dinini,
ırkını bilmediğim bir oyuncu koçu ile
yepyeni bir maceraya hazırlanmak.
Ne bileyim yepyeni şeyler, yepyeni
insanlar, yepyeni oyuncularla başka bir
festivalde karşılaşmak ve oynadıktan sonra
gece yatıp onları düşünüp
ben ne yapıyorum deyip gece yarısı kalkıp
deneyler yapmak,
jestini, mimiğini değiştirmek,
ses tonunla oynamak.
Bunların hepsi çok büyük
keşifler benim için.
Hala keşfediyorum.
Kısacası kendinden tüm o ödüllerden,
takdirden, kurallardan kurtulup her gün
yeniden, yeniden, yeniden
iyiliğe kaçmayı çok seviyorum.
Burada bugün gülümseyenleriniz oldu,
sıkılanlarınız, saatine bakanlar oldu
öfleyip püfleyenler oldu.
Ama o önemli değil şu anda şu kadarcık
zaman diliminde
on sekiz dakikayı geçmişim,
oyun arkadaşım oldunuz ve
buna istinaden hepinize teşekkür ediyorum.
Madem böyle bir bağ kurduk, samimiyetinize
istinaden
bir son sözle cümlelerimi bitirmek
istiyorum.
Her birimiz buradan çıktıktan sonra oyunu
nasıl oynamak istiyorsak öyle oynayalım.
Fakat kaybedenlerin sürekli kaybetmediği,
kazananların sürekli kazanmadığı
bir dünya için hep beraber,
her gün,
hep birlikte, hep hep hep iyiliğe kaçalım.
Hep.
Teşekkürler.